This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Every day, workers at grocery stores and convenience stores in Montana carry out a sad ritual. The first thing I do when I come on in is I go check the rotation on my milk and check my dates of course. That's Ken Carson. He's a dairy manager at a grocery store in Montana. And every day when he gets in, he checks the sell-by date on his milk. If it's past the date, the milk must be thrown out. These are all 20s that I'm pulling off. This one is dated the 18th and I will have to pour this one down the drain.
这里是“99%无形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。每天，蒙大拿州的杂货店和便利店里的工人们都在进行一个悲伤的仪式。我上班时做的第一件事就是去检查牛奶的轮转情况，当然还要检查日期。那是肯·卡森。他是蒙大拿州一家杂货店的乳品经理。他每天上班时，都会检查牛奶上的保质期。如果过了这个日期，牛奶就必须被扔掉。这些全都是我要倒掉的20号牛奶。这瓶日期是18号，我得把它倒进下水道里。
I have probably six of them. Ken is originally from Washington State, where he also worked in the grocery business. When I came here four years ago, I had no idea that they were pouring down as much milk down the drain as they have been. In fact, it was repulsive and sickening the first couple of weeks here. I was hundreds of gallons. There's nothing wrong with it. Pouring out milk happens, to some extent, in grocery stores all over the country. That's reporter Meredith Hodnott. But Montana throws much more of it down the drain than most places, because the cell
我大概有六瓶这样的。肯原本来自华盛顿州，他也在那里从事过杂货行业。四年前我刚来这里时，根本不知道他们竟然倒掉了这么多的牛奶。事实上，在这里的前几周，这简直让人感到恶心和反胃。那是几百加仑的牛奶。这牛奶本身没有任何问题。倒掉牛奶这种事，在全国各地的杂货店里都在一定程度上存在。这是记者梅雷迪思·霍德诺特。但是蒙大拿州倒进下水道的牛奶比大多数地方都要多，因为这里的
by date on the milk is required by state law to be just 12 days after pasteurization. The industry standard is 21 days. After these 12 days, Montana law requires that the milk be thrown away. It can't be sold or donated. It seems such a waste. I've got families that earn need. And we're doing this. Montana is throwing out so much milk in fact.
根据州法律，牛奶上的销售日期要求在巴氏杀菌后仅仅12天。行业标准是21天。过了这12天，蒙大拿州法律就要求把牛奶扔掉。它不能被销售，也不能被捐赠。这看起来太浪费了。我有许多需要帮助的家庭。而我们却在这样做。事实上，蒙大拿州扔掉了如此之多的牛奶。
The price of milk there is about two dollars per gallon higher than it is in surrounding states. And it's all because of the state label. In theory, Montana's strict state label law is about food safety and protecting the consumer. But it hasn't been updated since the 80s. of course aren't just on milk. They're on a lot of products. Used by, sell by, best by, best if used by, but then some products I expires on or have an EXP which is a shorthand for expires. This is Emily Broadleab, director of the Food Law and Policy Clinic at Harvard Law School. She did a tally of all the different kinds of date labeling. What we found was that 41 states required a date label on at least some food product. She says there are huge inconsistencies, not just in the wording, but in the meaning of these labels.
那里的牛奶价格比周边州每加仑高出大约两美元。这一切都是因为州政府的标签规定。从理论上讲，蒙大拿州严格的州标签法是为了食品安全和保护消费者。但它自20世纪80年代以来就没有更新过。当然，这些标签不仅限于牛奶。它们存在于许多产品上。保质期、销售期、最佳食用期、在此日期前最佳，但有些产品上写的是“失效于”或有EXP字样，这是失效（expires）的简写。这是埃米莉·布罗德利布，哈佛法学院食品法律与政策诊所的主任。她统计了所有不同类型的日期标签。我们发现，41个州要求至少在某些食品上贴上日期标签。”她说，不仅在措辞上，而且在这些标签的含义上，都存在巨大的不一致。
Some states require them only on dairy, some on shellfish, some on any perishable foods. And then 20 of those states actually restrict the sale or donation of food after the date. Some of them are quite strict. Some of them like flat out ban the sale or donation of food after the date. And some of them just say, we're going to make it complicated. The powers that be have definitely succeeded in making it complicated to decipher these dates, or to know how to act on them for large retailers and individual consumers alike. This is a bad system, it's not making people safer, it's leading to food waste and the dates really aren't safety-based. That's right, the date labels on our food are not about food safety and they were never actually meant to be.
一些州只要求在乳制品上贴标签，一些在贝类上，还有一些在任何易腐食品上。然后，这其中的20个州实际上限制了日期之后的食品销售或捐赠。其中一些相当严格。有些甚至彻底禁止在日期之后销售或捐赠食品。还有一些则表示，我们要把它搞得复杂一点。当权者确实成功地让普通零售商和个人消费者都难以解读这些日期，或者不知道该如何根据这些日期采取行动。这是一个糟糕的系统，它没有让人变得更安全，反而导致了食物浪费，而且这些日期根本不是基于安全的。没错，我们食品上的日期标签与食品安全无关，而且它们从来都不是为了安全。
But let's back up. It all began in the 1970s. Americans had moved farther away from their food sources. They were eating more packaged foods and getting more of their food in supermarkets. And they wanted a way to measure how fresh their food was. Most manufacturers already put encrypted dates on their products to help retailers rotate stock. And consumers craved access to this information. In 1977, the New York State Consumer Protection Board published a booklet called Blind Dates. How to Break the Codes on the Foods You Buy. The booklet told consumers how to decipher the encrypted date codes on their favorite products. The board distributed more than 10,000 copies and posted the booklet in supermarkets.
但让我们回顾一下。这一切始于20世纪70年代。美国人搬得离食物来源越来越远了。他们吃更多的包装食品，从超市获得更多的食物。他们想要一种衡量食物新鲜度的方法。大多数制造商已经在产品上印上了加密日期，以帮助零售商轮换库存。消费者渴望获得这些信息。1977年，纽约州消费者保护委员会出版了一本名为《盲目约会：如何破解你购买的食物上的密码》的小册子。这本小册子告诉消费者如何解读他们最喜欢的产品上的加密日期代码。该委员会分发了10,000多册，并将小册子贴在超市里。
Eventually, consumers started to demand that these dates be put clearly on packages, that they shouldn't have to get a special book and decipher a code. And that seems pretty reasonable. Consumers asked for date labels, so retailers and growth resource responded, but at that time everyone acknowledged this is really about quality and about freshness No one said I want a label because I'm afraid it won't be safe So a few states began to regulate these state labels Massachusetts was the first state that actually required date labels on food
最终，消费者开始要求将这些日期清楚地标在包装上，他们不应该为了解密一个代码而去买一本特殊的小册子。这似乎很合理。消费者要求贴日期标签，所以零售商和杂货商作出了回应，但在当时，所有人都承认这实际上关乎品质和新鲜度，没有人说“我想要个标签，因为我担心它不安全”。于是，一些州开始规范这些州标签。马萨诸塞州是第一个真正在食品上强制要求日期标签的州。
But there was no federal level regulation even though there were a number of attempts and one congress I think from 1973 to 75 there were 10 number of attempts. In one Congress, I think from 1973 to 1975, there were 10 bills on date labeling standardization. None of them passed. Lawmakers disagreed about what the system should look like and who should oversee it. The Food and Drug Administration has actually said, we could do this, we have the power to do it
但并没有联邦层面的监管，尽管有过多次尝试。在某一届国会中，我想从1973年到75年，关于日期标签标准化有10项提案。没有一项获得通过。立法者对这个系统应该是什么样子以及谁应该监督它意见不一。食品药品监督管理局其实已经说过，我们可以做到这一点，我们有权做到这一点，
for the foods we oversee. But since these labels were about freshness and not about safety, ultimately, the FDA said, it's not something we want to spend the time and energy on. Still, consumers wanted freshness dates, so all kinds of different ones popped up. Some were stamped on, some printed on the label. There was no consistency in how this information was displayed or the language that was used. Some companies even tried to promote these dates to sell their
针对我们监管的食品。但既然这些标签关乎新鲜度而非安全性，最终，FDA表示，这不是我们想要花费时间和精力的事情。尽管如此，消费者仍然想要保鲜日期，于是各种各样的日期标签涌现出来。有些是盖上去的，有些是印在标签上的。这些信息的显示方式或使用的语言没有任何一致性。一些公司甚至试图利用这些日期来推销他们的
products. Like, hey, buy Pepsi because it's going to give you that date to tell you it's fresher than all the other soft drinks. Some things just don't need a date stand on them to tell you how fresh they are. Not so with Diacolus, until now. Now, dipepsy introduces freshness dating from dipepsy. Some date labels were meant for consumers, while others were just meant for retailers. And as is still true now, there were no clear definitions for any of the phrases. No consistency, even within the same brand or product.
产品。比如，嘿，买百事可乐吧，因为它会给你提供那个日期，告诉你它比所有其他的软饮料都要新鲜。有些东西根本不需要在上面标个日期来告诉你它们有多新鲜。百事可乐可不是这样，直到现在。现在，百事可乐推出了百事可乐的保鲜日期。一些日期标签是给消费者看的，而另一些则只是给零售商看的。而且就像现在依然如此的那样，没有任何一个短语有明确的定义。甚至在同一个品牌或产品内部也没有一致性。
Dates could differ from state to state, manufacturer to manufacturer, or store to store. And over the years, we've lost track of what these labels meant in the first place. As time goes on and on, and more and more people grow up just being used to having labels on their food. No one's ever said to them what they mean and what they don't.
日期可能因州而异，因制造商而异，或者因商店而异。多年来，我们已经忘记了这些标签最初的含义。随着时间的推移，越来越多的人长大成人，他们已经习惯了食物上有标签。从来没有人告诉过他们这些标签到底意味着什么，不意味着什么。
So we've made some false connections. So people in their head have made this link and thought, well, I heard about someone getting salmonella or E. coli, and I see this label on my food, and these two things are somehow connected to one another. But Emily says, as much as we might want them to, these dates are not going to tell us if our food will make us sick. People keep saying, well, but I just want to know when it will be safe until.
所以我们做出了错误的关联。因此，人们在脑海中建立了这种联系，心想，嗯，我听说有人得了沙门氏菌或大肠杆菌，而我在食物上看到了这个标签，这两者之间在某种程度上是有联系的。但埃米莉说，不管我们多么希望如此，这些日期都不会告诉我们食物是否会让我们生病。人们一直在说，嗯，但我只是想知道它在什么时候之前是安全的。
It's scientifically impossible to sort of say there's a date after which it will become unsafe. Milk is actually a good example of this. If you run a few errands on a hot day before getting your milk home, your milk will spoil faster. And once it's in the fridge, it'll last longer at, say, 35 degrees than at 40 degrees. There's just too many variables. But here's the thing about spoiled milk. Spoiled milk doesn't mean it has pathogens in it. That's because the harmful pathogens in milk are removed during the pasturization process,
从科学上讲，不可能说存在一个日期，过了这个日期它就会变得不安全。牛奶其实就是一个很好的例子。如果你在热天把牛奶拿回家之前先去办几件差事，你的牛奶就会变质得更快。一旦它进了冰箱，比如在35华氏度下保存的时间会比在40华氏度下更长。变量实在太多了。但关于变质的牛奶，情况是这样的。牛奶变质并不意味着它里面有病原体。这是因为牛奶中的有害病原体在巴氏杀菌过程中被去除了，
along with most other bacteria. The big misconception around date labels is that people think that old food will make them sick, but for the most part, old food doesn't make you sick, contaminated food does. A longer a carton of milk exists, the more chance it has to come into contact with contaminants that could grow and flourish inside that milk and hurt you. But as long as it's properly pastorized,
连同大多数其他细菌一起。围绕日期标签的最大误解是，人们认为变质的食物会让他们生病，但大部分情况下，变质的食物不会让你生病，受污染的食物才会。一盒牛奶存在的时间越长，它接触到污染物的机会就越多，这些污染物可能会在那盒牛奶内部滋生、繁衍并伤害你。但只要它经过适当的巴氏杀菌，
there's nothing about the age specifically that makes milk dangerous to drink. There is, however, a small handful of foods that can become unsafe with age. Deli meets unpasserized cheeses, smoked seafood, stuff in the deli section of the grocery store, basically. These foods have a high risk for Listeria, a bacteria that can be life-threatening. And in these cases, Listeria risk does increase with time. But our current date labeling system doesn't treat this small subset of foods any differently than any other date labeled item.
牛奶本身并没有什么年龄上的特征让它变得危险而不能饮用。然而，确实有一小部分食物随着时间的推移会变得不安全。熟食肉类、未经巴氏杀菌的奶酪、熏海鲜，基本上就是杂货店熟食区的东西。这些食物感染李斯特菌的风险很高，这是一种可能危及生命的细菌。在这些情况下，李斯特菌的风险确实随时间而增加。但我们目前的日期标签系统并没有将这一小部分食品与任何其他贴有日期的商品区别对待。
Most date labels are arrived at by conducting taste tests. They sit people around a table and then they have everyone eat their product. Say it's yogurt. They taste a batch made that day. And then they taste some from the day before. And the day before that. And they say, well, what did you think? Was it good?
大多数日期标签是通过进行味觉测试得出的。他们让人们坐在一张桌子周围，然后让每个人吃他们的产品。假设是酸奶。他们品尝当天制作的一批。然后他们品尝前一天的。还有再前一天的。他们会说，嗯，你觉得怎么样？好不好吃？
Was it tasty? Did it have the properties you expect from yogurt or whatever the product is? And when the manufacturer comes to a batch, the people say, I don't really like the way this tastes. They say, okay, well, after that many days, our product's not going to be at its peak. And that's where the date really comes from.
它好吃吗？它具备你对酸奶或任何产品的预期属性吗？当制造商遇到某一批产品时，人们说，我真的不太喜欢这个味道。他们说，好吧，过了这么多天，我们的产品将不再处于最佳状态。日期也就是这么来的。
So the dates in our food are arrived at through a taste test or sometimes, especially with smaller companies, they just guess. They've said, you know, I feel awful about it, but we don't have money to bring in and do this whole taste test. We just, you know, we look online for an estimate of how long this food will be fresh or we just kind of say, like, well, you know, I only keep it in my refrigerator for three days, so I'll put three days on it. There's some of them are very unscientific about where that date actually comes from. And yet today according to a report that Emily Broadleab co-authored,
因此，我们食物上的日期是通过味觉测试得出的，有时，特别是对于小公司来说，他们只是瞎猜。他们说，你知道，我对这感到很糟糕，但我们没有钱请人来做整个味觉测试。我们只是，你知道的，我们在网上寻找这种食物能保持新鲜多久的估计，或者我们只是有点像，嗯，你知道，我只在冰箱里放三天，所以我就在上面标三天。其中一些人对于日期的来源非常不科学。然而今天，根据埃米莉·布罗德利布共同撰写的一份报告，
a majority of consumers believe that eating food past its sell-by or used-by date is risked to their health. And as many as 90% of Americans throw out food based on day labels, at least occasionally. We're throwing out billions of pounds of food here in America, simply because of misunderstanding of those code dates. This is Doug Rau, former president of Trader Joe's. He's been in the grocery business for more than 40 years. In 2015, he founded Daily Table, a non-profit retail store that sells pre-made meals sourced from food that would otherwise be wasted.
大多数消费者认为，吃过了销售期或最佳食用期的食物会对他们的健康构成风险。高达90%的美国人至少偶尔会根据日期标签扔掉食物。我们在美国扔掉了数十亿磅的食物，仅仅是因为对这些代码日期的误解。这是道格·劳，前乔氏超市（Trader Joe's）总裁。他在杂货行业工作了40多年。2015年，他创立了“日常餐桌”（Daily Table），这是一个非营利性零售商店，出售由原本会被浪费的食物制成的预制餐食。
We waste a staggering amount of food. The average American waste somewhere between 20 and 25% of the food they acquire. And it's not just wasting the food, it's wasting the water to grow it, the transportation to get it to the supermarket, everything that goes into getting food to your plate. Doug and Emily both say that to make date labels serve us better and to waste less food, we need to consider the language we're using. Sell by, use by, enjoy by.
我们浪费了惊人数量的食物。普通美国人浪费了他们获取的食物的20%到25%左右。这不仅是浪费食物，还浪费了种植它所需的水，将其运送到超市的交通运输，以及将食物送到你盘子里所涉及的一切。道格和埃米莉都表示，要让日期标签更好地为我们服务并减少食物浪费，我们需要考虑我们正在使用的语言。在此之前销售、在此之前食用、在此之前享用。
Like, what does that mean, you know? And the idea of an expiration date is problematic, too. If something's expired, it's dead. If your credit card's expired, it's dead. You can't use it. Heaven forbid, your dog expired. You know, there's no more life. Well, no one's interested in expired food.
就像，那是什么意思，你知道的？而且“保质期”（expiration date）这个概念也是有问题的。如果什么东西过期了，它就死了。如果你的信用卡过期了，它就死了。你不能用它了。老天保佑，你的狗过期了。你知道的，没有生命了。嗯，没有人对过期的食物感兴趣。
No one's interested in eating dead food. I actually prefer most of my food dead. But the point is this, when food is perceived as an edible, you can't do anything with it. Nobody wants to eat it, and you can't give it to a food pantry. And a lot of states have laws that actually forbid the donation of so-called expired food. Emily suggests only using the term expired for foods that actually do become unsafe at the time. Those unpasturized cheeses and deli meats. For everything else, she would go with best if used by.
没有人有兴趣吃死去的食物。实际上我更喜欢我大部分的食物是死的。但关键是这样的，当食物被认为是不可食用的，你就拿它没办法了。没有人想吃它，你也不能把它送给食物救济库。许多州的法律实际上禁止捐赠所谓的过期食品。埃米莉建议只对那些在那个时候确实变得不安全的食物使用“过期”这个词。那些未经巴氏杀菌的奶酪和熟食肉类。对于所有其他东西，她会选择“在此日期前食用最佳”。
So there would be two labels, expires on and best if used by. And this would be a standardized system used all across the country. Creating standardized, easy to understand date labels is a design problem that must have a design solution. Maybe Emily suggested labels or maybe something else entirely. The fix doesn't seem like it should be that hard. And yet. Most of the time when we say this is an issue that needs to change people say I agree it's a terrible issue.
因此将有两个标签：在此失效和在此日期前食用最佳。这将是一个在全国各地使用的标准化系统。创建标准化、易于理解的日期标签是一个必须有设计解决方案的设计问题。也许埃米莉建议了标签，或者完全是别的什么。修复这个问题似乎不应该那么难。然而。大多数时候，当我们说这是一个需要改变的问题时，人们会说我同意，这是一个糟糕的问题。
But then people really get stuck up on which phrase should we use and how do we decide which foods have which one. These are the very same questions that tied up regulation the first time around in the 1970s, but the stakes are different this time, because food waste is now a part of a national conversation. The EPA and USDA announced a goal to cut food waste in the U.S. in half by 2030, and having a better date labeling system is one way to get there. But for now, Emily is happy to help settle your more micro level disputes.
但随后人们真正纠结于我们应该使用哪个短语，以及我们如何决定哪些食物对应哪一个。这正是20世纪70年代第一次绑架法规的那些问题，但这次的利害关系不同了，因为食物浪费现在是国家对话的一部分。环保局和美国农业部宣布了一个目标，即到2030年将美国的食物浪费减半，而拥有一个更好的日期标签系统是实现这一目标的方法之一。但就目前而言，埃米莉很高兴能帮你解决更微观层面的争端。
Basically, the answer is, trust your taste, not the date. So the story that I heard most from friends, from family, from colleagues, and I continue to hear now is that, you know, there's someone that says, I'm so glad you put this report at it because I've been telling my wife for years that the dates don't matter, and now I'm really vindicated or you know vice versa. So instead of arguing over date labels you should take part in that other ritual that happens between spouses and front of the refrigerator where you open up a dodgy carton of something rather and ask does this smell okay to you?
基本上，答案是：相信你的味觉，而不是日期。因此，我从朋友、家人、同事那里听到最多并继续听到的故事是，你知道，有人说，我很高兴你发表了这份报告，因为我多年来一直告诉我的妻子日期并不重要，现在我真的被证明是对的，或者你知道的，反之亦然。所以，与其为日期标签争吵不休，你不如参与配偶之间和冰箱前发生的另一个仪式，在那里你打开某种乱七八糟的东西的可疑纸盒，然后问：你觉得这闻起来还好吗？
99% invisible was produced this week by Meredith Hotnaught and Katie Mingle, with a reach of men Sam Green's fan Kurt Colstead and me Roman Mars. The tape you heard at the beginning of the story with the Montana Grocer was collected by the Harvard Food Law and Policy Clinic and racing horse productions for a short film they produced about date labels, special thanks to Rebecca Richmond Cohen and Daniel Hansen. We are a project of 91.7K ALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxine, an architecture and interiors firm, in out more about this story, including cool pictures and links and listen to all the episodes of 99% invisible. You must go to 99pi.org.
本周的“99%无形”由梅雷迪思·霍德诺特和凯蒂·明格制作，山姆·格林斯潘、库尔特·科尔斯特德以及我罗曼·马尔斯协助。你在故事开头听到的关于蒙大拿杂货商的录音是由哈佛食品法律与政策诊所以及赛马场制作公司为他们制作的一部关于日期标签的短片而收集的，特别感谢丽贝卡·里士满·科恩和丹尼尔·汉森。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的项目，在建筑和室内设计公司Arxine的办公室制作。要了解关于这个故事的更多信息，包括酷炫的图片和链接，并收听“99%无形”的所有单集，你必须访问99pi.org。
Radio Tapio. From PRX. PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自PRX的塔皮奥电台。PRX。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。